I'd risk coming again through volcanic
ash clouds anything to go is its Fanta
terrorist attack I've actually always
been a nervous flier to be honest and I
flew a few weeks after 9/11 and um and
after 9/11 the world went a little bit
crazy you know understandably the rules
changed there was a lot of anger and
fear and confusion and finger-pointing
and then I'd always consider myself
quite a rational liberal sort of guy and
I try to remain that way after 9/11 and
even in like in the pub with mates
I'd be the ones going no you can't say
that now that's a generalization that's
that's ridiculous no no that's that's
unfair you can't tie over the same brush
no it's still the safest form of
transport is 16 million to one the
chance of her you know trying to be
rational that's in a pub when I'm flying
it's more like check him again can we
check him again he's getting on this but
do you mind if I check him can I just
can I just and after 9/11 with all the
checks I still tried to remain sort of
rational for the so I was thinking right
it's it's harder now than it ever was to
get a bomb on the plane this is you know
it's it's the restrictions are tight
it's safe for now and then I found out
that a terrorist doesn't have to get on
the plane now with the bomb they found
heat-seeking missiles and they could
just Park up in some sort of lay by and
take the plane out within the first 10
minutes of takeoff so now I'd be on the
plane going right we're out of range
who's got the bomb right and as I saw I
flew a couple of weeks after 9/11 an
internal flight and we're up in the air
I've done the thing right we're out of
range right okay I was a little bit
nervous and I said to the air hostess I
said have you got any magazines think of
this she said quite loud quite blase she
said no honey
we've got no magazines we've had to
undertake severe cutbacks because we're
one of the companies being sued over
9/11 one don't mention 9/11
surely a new rule but went round
don't mention 911 when you're handing
out the coffee just you know I mean but
- don't say severe cutbacks severe
cutbacks if someone says no I don't
think of magazines anymore I think of a
bloke in the aircraft hangar earlier
that week going do we really need all
these rivets
it's just what terrible bedside manner I
mean I take first-class flights
everywhere I know you wouldn't have any
other way I'd do it for you really some
of the flights I take cost ten thousand
pounds okay and for ten thousand pounds
in a disaster I expect the front end of
my plane that I'm in to gently break off
and float down to a desert island it
doesn't I'll die with the rest you
[ __ ] losers that's not fair isn't it
I know you tried to save me but you
couldn't eat we just be on the news I'd
probably only one get name-checked on
the news you'd be turned in thirty
others but I was his son consolation but
anyway so okay once I was flying back
from New York okay
925 a Saturday night JFK to London
Heathrow be a first-class okay now this
is my point it's fear that threatens
rational thought I think okay I'm there
now the whole week leading up to that
flight either if you remember it always
happened more than once I don't know it
was a couple years ago on every news
channel in America there was a rolling
ticker tape that said America on red
alert we've had intel there's going to
be another 9/11 in a major city probably
New York or LA okay
this weekend do not fly unless you
absolutely had to write I had to I was
filming and
but so I'm the only one in the
first-class lounge okay and I still
tried to remain rash and I was thinking
no it's safe for now everyone's looking
for a terrorist today they leave it till
Monday all right and then it happened
the thing that threatened my rational
thought I have a little bit of a mini
breakdown into the first-class lounge
about 30 minutes before boarding came
this guy I don't know where there is
North African or Middle Eastern or Asian
but you had all the gear all right beard
steer the tosh.o case ok and here's your
middle-class sort of liberal I went
I was suddenly engaging staff in sort of
banal conversation but flight on time
they go yeah what's the weather like in
London like they were gonna go it's a
bit cloudy but there is right didn't
happen so I'm left there right and I'm
looking over him and I'm thinking of all
the running up to it and the week I'm
gonna tell the news nothing but now
there's a fight between good and evil
between rational and irrational okay
this one goes oh that's a suicide bomber
oh very stupid course it isn't
it is how'd you know that's what he look
like
Wow beard day me stupid right then he
makes a phone call and I couldn't
understand what he was saying be sounded
a bit angry okay
this one goes all we made a phone call
right this what no you just made a phone
call
yeah but not in foreign a sharp right
he's been checked without the rest of us
have been checked did they check the
beard yeah they checked the beard yeah
and then I'm looking at him
must be an absent-minded with all this
going on in my head and he catches me
looking and he does this
because all we knows he knows right
this will goes no he knows why you're
looking at me said that sort of
prejudice for months now stop looking at
him yeah right
but this one starts winning the fear
starts beating all the rational thought
in the world it's not going no it could
be well yeah it could be probably not
well know the stats are up today yeah
but still but it won't happen don't say
it won't happen to us people of 9/11
said it wouldn't happen to them yeah but
all the tests yeah where they find new
ways of getting through our detection
then we have to up their game yeah
you're right and suddenly I thought oh
my god this is it this is it and wave of
nausea and you suddenly realize oh my
god I'm witnessing this
this one goes ok right let's report him
this one goes no why in case someone
thinks we're racist no [ __ ] that
let's let's report him and be a wrong
embarrassed live racist just in case
right I don't know so I don't and so now
I think he is a suicide bomber and I
think I'm gonna get on the plane and die
but I'm not gonna do anything about it
and I'm nearly in tears and all this
happens in a few moments and I look over
and he's joined by his wife who's got
all the gear and it's two little girls
ok
and I suddenly go ah course he's not
[ __ ] suicide bomber if you're off to
see 72 virgins you don't take the wife
and kids and on so no it's true
and I got on the plane and of course he
wasn't a terrorist no I was sort of a
bit embarrassed and I saw the funny side
of it and I was relieved anything and
then it was a businessman and a family
man he was playing with his two little
girls I kept running up and down and
banging into my chair he wasn't doing
anything about that at all okay think
about that at all okay and he was sort
of chasing them and I was squealing
really I've been going through after
half an hour I was hoping some would
blow the [ __ ] plane up do y'all is
but a really weird thing happened during
that period I got so paranoid about
terrorists attacked I started taking
private jets and helicopters everywhere
just cuz I was so rich no it is so great
to be here doing stand-up for a group of
Muslims how can you tell the difference
between a regular Muslim and a terrorist
I have no idea and that's kind of the
problem isn't it
I want to react better to stuff I don't
really ill at stuff in my own head
anymore
yeah the best reaction to anything I saw
was in Glasgow last year Glasgow some
terrorists tried to drive a car bomb
into Glasgow Airport now they were
thwarted for a number of reasons one was
they couldn't get up enough speed to
enter the airport because they had to
keep going through roundabouts now we
die in the name of Allah let's go I have
to wait for him to come around first no
only when you get the whole gate now I
got it but there was the best react
there were two fantastic reactions one
was because the car came in one of the
guys got out on fire ran across the
terminal building and was rugby tackled
by a large Scottish man only in Scotland
would someone be standing there as a
burning man gets out of a car goes
[ __ ] watch this the best reaction
though is from an Englishman who was
interviewed at the same scene and this
guy I mean how do you describe what's
your point of reference when you see
something like that happening this was
the kindest description okay is it I
mean it was amazing this car came in
through the terminal building this man
got out smoked pluming from him
his clothes in shreds
he was charred he was staggering across
the terminal building I mean it was like
loving his own it was like a Michael
Jackson Thriller video
[Music]
she's our know it better than you made
the man chattering gospel they haven't
even covered villages for antiques they
thought the village with her
I saw the whole thing in New York on the
news I thought I would need an ambulance
[ __ ] eejits
the whole shoe is a bone shape that's it
just what a freak look do you want to
see just once the shoe is a moment
instructor
[Applause]
my ass what are you going to do 57 bill
did you just pour your balls off
I don't get it
because they yield John sweets it and I
know that said some ham since he's a
delightful man he was a baggage handler
at the airport in Egypt for a smoke
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] guys are fire people be
shattered
[Applause]
[Applause]
they needed them as well
that was the funniest thing attorney who
started them and he's been interviewed
by this woman she's all business through
some leafy some other perhaps to the
some attention John when the fries
when it's like a huge was that you
played at the child what was the charity
of play
Oh God
he said what is what is the Jeep on fire
and at the start of the fight he said so
why because in these places our menses
of the boy he said the flames were
she translates it but this is the one
[Applause]
but he did a thing which made me a
change of such a circuit right and
although you covered about us an example
is a macro cosmos with it and I prefer a
remarkably similar and I know you feel
assumed just sometimes we hear something
about you go she says have you anything
to see to tell us to a thicket of
ecology class
[Applause]
like
Oh
[Applause]
we should go maybe you won't join sweet
than giving challenges
[Applause]